bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que la france est
divisée sur le port du masque et surtout
sur sa capacité à nous protéger du virus
tout à fait oublier un schisme qui est
en train se produire qui est de plus en
plus forts de plus en plus durs entre
les pros masques et les antis masques et
c'est d'ailleurs une une division qui
regroupe un peu des classes d'âge 100
104 au généralité on voit que les jeunes
sont de plus en plus anti masque que
c'est quelque chose qui se sentent de
plus en plus comme une contrainte sur
leur corps alors qu'ils ne se sentent
pas en danger alors que les personnes
plus âgées vont avoir tendance non
seulement à respecter lors du match mais
à vouloir imposer qu'on le respecte dans
l'espace public
comment vous expliquer le refus de
porter ce masque
il faut dire que la communication sur le
masque c'est un peu le péché originel de
notre gouvernement et je crois qu'on en
paye toujours les conséquences même si
on a dit et répété beaucoup de choses
autour de ça c'est à dire que dès le
début les messages en ut d'une confusion
totale d'une contradiction totale autour
de cette question du port du masque est
que maintenant tout le monde peut s'en
emparer pour dire vous voyez à un moment
où d'ici un moment dit sarah beau monde
il faut le porter ici un autre moment on
dit il faut pas le porter là donc c'est
cette confusion qui est aujourd'hui
génératrice effectivement deux à la fois
d'incertitude et de colère et de
violence puis son compte
c'est toute la question de la confiance
au fond dans les discours de prévention
se posent autour de ça est ce que le
masque est réellement efficace
est ce que il protège réellement ou pas
tout le monde n'en est pas convaincu
aujourd'hui
alors c'est vrai que ces questions là on
se l'est posée juste avant le
confinement est justement il ya eu
plusieurs sons de cloches ce que vous
pensez que ça ça à semer la confusion
dans l'esprit des français
on se souvient qu'au niveau même de la
direction générale de la santé du
gouvernement vous expliquez que porter
un masque ce n'était pas forcément
nécessaire dans les espaces publics
absolument et ça on en paye les
conséquences aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'encore une fois ce discours
extrêmement contradictoires extrêmement
hésitants le
masques ne sert à rien le masque de
serre che qu'au personnel soignant il
n'a aucun impact de santé publique sur
la population on nous l'a quand même 10
2 à partir des plus hautes instances
scientifiques
donc on peut pas faire comme si
aujourd'hui ces messages là était
totalement effacée alors qu'il faut
répéter redire
des messages de plus en plus claire sur
la nécessité du port du masque il faut
dire que effectivement il ya des
inquiétudes nouvelles autour d'une rue
d'une reprise de l'épidémie alors on n'y
est pas encore mais il ya des
frémissements
il ya des indicateurs possibles expliqué
le mieux possible les choses aux plus
jeunes
alors il ya un phénomène très inquiétant
sont les violences liées justement à
l'obligation du port du masque ces
derniers temps ont par exemple ce
chauffeur de bus battu à mort à bayonne
un père de famille frappée à coups de
batte de base-ball dans une laverie une
infirmière aussi agressé dans un bus en
seine saint denis c'est plutôt
inquiétant
c'est très inquiétant et si vous voulez
je crois qu'il faut voir ça dans un
contexte plus global il ya une
inquiétude et une peur extrêmement
grande aujourd'hui par rapport à ce qui
va se passer à la rentrée parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'incertitudes autour de ça
beaucoup de gens savent qu'ils n'ont pas
de travail qui n'ont pas trouvé de
travail que leur entreprise est en péril
quel risque de fermer qu'il va y avoir
du chômage que ça va être très difficile
la rentrée scolaire la rentrée
universitaire tout ça aussi est très
incertain qu'est ce qui va se passer
et donc cette peur elle génère beaucoup
d'angoissé et il ya des personnes qui
retournent l'envoi sans violence qui
lorsque lorsque cette peur est trop
grande et bien une l'expulsent sous
fortes pentes de violences et on voit
dans le temps et dans l'espace public de
plus en plus quelque chose qui ce christ
est une violence mais même au delà de
cette violence extrême de de gens
frappés à coups de batte de baseball qui
reste heureusement marginaux il ya dans
l'espace public quelque chose qui s'est
beaucoup crispé une violence qui
apparaît de plus en plus entre les uns
et les autres et notamment autour de
cette question du port du masque j'ai
encore vu plusieurs fois des selles dans
des supermarchés où des gens se font
quasiment insulté quasiment maltraités
parce que
il ne porte pas de masque on comment
faire juste bon pour convaincre les
français de porter le masque
lorsque c'est obligatoire et justement
est-ce qu'il faut des sanctions est ce
que le gouvernement doit mener une
campagne pour justement sensibiliser au
port du masque obligatoire alors des
sanctions je dirais en dernier recours
le il faut vraiment être le plus
pédagogique possible expliqué et encore
une fois auprès des plus jeunes à voir
des discours très clair très carrée qui
des choses qui ne peuvent pas être
contredite et qui s'appuie sur des
vérités scientifiques qu'ils peuvent pas
être remises remise en question on doit
plus y avoir des termes vraiment autour
de cette ville port du masque il faut
que les messages soient encore une fois
extrêmement clair extrêmement carré le
professeur pialoux par exemple de
l'hôpital tenon et il a publié un
pamphlet actuellement dans les qualifs
il plaide pour ça il sait très bien ce
dont il parle puisqu'il commence à
revoir des gens qui reviennent qui
arrive à nouveau en réanimation dans z
entendez état grave et il dit bien très
clairement qu'il faut
comment dire on ne doit plus avoir
d'internement sur cette question du plan
du maski toutes les chaussures claire
carré et direct merci à vous serge hefez
un peu connaître psychiatre et
psychanalyste